ogni tanto mi capita di testare qualche
gioco nuovo no ho scoperto da poco un
gioco di guerra che è un vero e proprio
simulatore di guerra nel senso che non
ci sono i nomi sopra la testa dei
compagni quindi non li distingue dai
nemici ci sono un milione di armi per
caricare ci sono mille modi di caricare
per un simulatore di guerra ho voluto
vedere come nella realtà riuscirei a
cavarmela in guerra ho provato a
registrare il tutto a vedere che ne
usciva fuori
il risultato è questo raggiungere le
cose per iniziare stage si capisce
niente quanto grosso lo zaino dentro uno
zaino che treni che 3d feih1 attenzione
non si fa a tenere assicurate e filtro
gioco e questo gioco oggi su grazie
vedo che ha fatto benissimo e abbiamo
delle armi siamo siamo bilanciati noto
io sono partito con un coltello e tu hai
un coltello più grosso non ci sono i
nomi sulla testa delle persone quindi
noi possiamo tranquillamente ammazzarci
siccome c'era in un'arma da fuoco
questo coltello potrebbe accidentalmente
finire tra i tuoi glutei liste non ci
provare il libro di guardare dove spari
per cortesia e di guardare dove spari
per cortesia accetta spetta a due amici
muovere occhio che ci spariamo a vicenza
io sento degli spari provenire non
adesso io sono io sono io sono io che ho
già detto vado devi di guardare dove
spari per cortesia ma porca di una pacca
masse di uno ti dice non sparare sono io
ma cosa ti hanno insegnato in guerra
sono delle gallerie bruttissime però una
pistola
anch'io sono in un tunnel non sparare a
primo che vede solo per ios e di uno
smart ayane che lo vogliono morto sono
molto moderno chi è stato ucciderti e
non lo sai come del tuo corpo ti aspetta
mi sono caricato forte non solo è
arrivato un proiettile da qualche parte
vi sono cagata dove siamo forti a scopi
agli omicidi in server for non possiamo
perderci chiama richiamo che quasi la
vecchia ma la donna parkour poi
bravissimi 38 pezzetto che adegua c'è
qualcuno zitto per la poca però io
labora partito non riapre a così si apre
caffè perfetto se tiri calci non si apre
se la precedentemente si apre attenzione
sempre f è nuda le cose vediamo se c'è
qualcosa searching e ho trovato una red
bull a po vale delle sigarette a postel
abbiamo vinto la guerra
il lotto impiega un po di un iphone a
posto e rotto però uno stendino mio
amico sento questa te ne fai ha tra
l'altro la rai 2 si chiama red bull
gabbiano rosso 1 sembra come uscire ma
soffriamo noi non sappiamo come uscire
quello è fatto capito perché kakà ma tu
sei stupido ma se arriva vita qua come
fa essere qua andare abbandonata c'era
qui ma dove avevano una donna ma io sono
i sogni sono io ma se in fondo come fa a
essere tu sei quello no non sai santana
non sei tu io gli sparo maledizione dico
porca vacca il c'è gente c'è gente
secondo me è più alto che spara 5 e
l'altro lei tu il fondo ce n'è uno
poniamo lasciamolo 6 era un tipo essi
saranno rifugiato dentro spara spara lo
abbia ucciso mio figlio il tipo ucciso o
meno male e sei un cretino momenti così
dove il tizio che dietro di te non so
nulla
casagrande ecco aiaf che male tua madre
morta
vabbè rende numero 5 tra l'altro
operator martino giarrizzo non sparate
siete voi che lo chiedete conferma
salerno dicendo ciao ciao ciao pato
poche di sono doveri morto prima che
occhio situ o c'è un tizio su un tizio
occhio se tu non parla minimo ammazzo
quindi se veramente sono cazzi suoi
prima scala su due già dietro di te sono
io dietro di te sono io
como 1 col coltello nè uno nè pietro
mazza vorrei pietro non mi conosci
distinguo chi è morto mio mai a timo
rosmarino ne parliamo sentono morto
degli oscar
yo yo no se si stanno incrociando questi
due li ho visti lucido io molto piano
per endesa morte moric e mondo ma deciso
credo di sì e che bello che ho fatti
vedere
mica sempre in volta il white con una
sigaretta in bocca tra l'altro quando
sei trasgressivo ma voi perché tu hai un
m quadro c'è uno dietro che salta sono
io e salta sono io sono sparate il caso
era non lo so però spara libri che ci
ammazzi ci sono più scuse per me ne sono
accorto emergente cornia però da mi darò
da sciami l'allarme lascia milano ma ciò
ecco ce n'è uno per terra c'è una morto
c'è un morto qui e qui vai a vista su
chi è stato maledizione era un pelato
perché tutti i pelati so misto gioco e
queste sono le epiche avventure di fan
ejeie i suoi amici stupidi in guerra
come siamo dei bravi ragazzi abbiamo
provato anche a giocare a un altro gioco
di guerra ma che sul quale siamo molto
più skillati di colori prima che fra
noi abbiamo fatto una partita accorta ma
merita di essere vista
sei molto più bello mi ha fatto male per
tutto un deficiente era poi così delitto
dritto dritto
ecco adesso vedi investito bravo questo
è un gioco fatto bene siamo pratico che
siamo bravi come mussini amici persone
aiuto questo è un giorno ho fatto bene
siamo pratica che i ragazzi questa non
dietro breve su come non andare in
battaglia era un paio di persone lucci
social ciò molto più volte di quante
volte ho ucciso però spero che vi sia
comunque avere dietro di squadra era uno
svantaggio a prescindere quindi capitemi
almeno per ora vive sia piaciuto ragazzi
cose dice proceduto al momento e mi
piace anche i vari social con vivida
descrizione social si rischia trinci
mediano prossimo video per ragazzi
[Musica]